le questionner alors le votre mot
préféré sur emmanuel ya là ce qui veut
dire en avant lui ce que j'ai dit comme
ça que j'ai dit ah bon dieu en un mot
que vous détestez stop jamais charité
dans la vie jamais faut toujours courir
s'acharner et on est toujours toujours
bec canton
sacha pas de stop mais votre drogue
oui c'est ça votre favorite de drogue
favorite en ballons là moi je pense que
vous allez me répondre jésus vous voulez
quelque chose de matériel la non nous on
vous répond de ce couvent où la chose
lors l'astuce l'astuce pour malte et où
j'ai vu il n'y a rien de commun entre
eux au point de vue de quelque chose que
j'aime dans ma bouche c'est l'astuce
pour maltais bokoyoï champagne très bien
si ce mot n'a mon père ma vie ma force
mon enthousiasme c'est judas c'est juste
le son le bruit que vous aimez c'est le
sa levée reggina des moines de lérins
c'est très extraordinaire il le chante
le soin après conflit dans leur église
tout est en sus lance tout est sombre
la vierge est légèrement illuminé et le
chalut oren tu as qu'est notre espoir
c'est vraiment l'humanité du cri était
sûr que finalement battu finira bien
très bien
j'enregistre ça va ça va le son le bruit
que vous détestez alors là j'ai noté le
haut parleur pour un mort pendant le
ou par le pour un mort si vous étiez au
caire vous comprendriez ah oui d'accord
mais sur scène pour un habitat sain je
conçois tout à coup ça comment vous êtes
saisis
saül jusqu'à ligne le haut parleur pour
amorcer sa vraiment y'a rien alors ma
soeur j'excuse la pose cette question
votre jure au gros mot blasphème je ne
pense pas espèce de charme aux espèces
de chameau c'est joli c'est un parce que
lui chabou en afrique est un animal
noble
c'est le plus grand compliment qu'on
puisse faire un homme c'est de lui dire
qu'à match c'est-à-dire chameau un mou
femmes pour illustrer un nouveau billet
de banque
pascal le métier que vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire sur un manuel chauffeur de
poids lourd pourquoi à ce que j'ai connu
des chauffeurs de poids lourds qui sont
partis dijoux qui sont revenus dans leur
appartement
l'appartement vide la femme partie avec
le gauche jamais oublier sa medi
chauffeur de pâles ou c'est un mauvais
mec
bon la plante l'arbre où l'animal dans
lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné ne
pas lui d'egypte n'y a rien de plus beau
de plus je ne sais pas moi depuis
artistique que le palier des jupes qui
laisse pour bêcher date à quai la honte
à né pas schaaf et enfin alors c'est la
question que je vais je faire le tour
puis je reviendrai à vous donc la
dernière question évidemment elle est de
circonstance pour un vendredi saint si
dieu existe
qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire à vous paulo coelho
vous avez combattu le bon combat
les faits le bon combat décrire ici
diront que si dieu existe moi j'aimerais
qu'il dise simplement enfin s'il avait
la bonté d'ajouter c'est la fête alors
ce serait parfait n'est champagne que me
dirait asti spumante astuces comment
alors jean claude petit j'aimerais
qu'ils me disent vient pour la fête
vient pour le festin vient boire manger
danser tout le monde est invité ni
compris les clandestins ne le copain
bien j'allais un peu répété les autres
mais j'aimerais qu'ils me disent attend
encore quelques années et je t'offrirai
de la stib commenté que dû boire avec
soeur emmanuelle
mais pour être plus sérieux puisque pour
moi la foi est un pari pari sur dur sur
l'homme
je pense qu'il me dirais tu as gagné son
pari et qu'il ajouterait je crois en
l'homme c'est beau alors il vous serait
alors que si dieu existe alors je répète
la question si dieu existe soeur
emmanuelle
ok il existe et dont qui vous arrive de
douter
c'est vrai voilà si dieu existe
qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort que je
souhaite le plus tard possible vous
entendre vous dire à vous dire à dieu
existe et il me dira vie dit il est
amené à vient au mac bien aimé et je lui
dirai je suis l'homme bien nenê
formidable ça vous êtes un personnage au
caire à mon avis sont pas embêtés agents
dans 20 ans
alors les chiffonniers ça je comprends
pourquoi vous avez les chiffres ont été
si populaire auprès d'eux alors
maintenant je comprends
[Musique]